uh gabe here says about true social
trump launched his true social app on
president's day because of course he did
get ready for the presidential flop
gabe's making some predictions here
sign up and sign in errors of course or
if you can sign in at all sign up or
sign in at all
uh d-a-u and m-a-u will be sub-optimal i
don't know what that means that must be
tech talk
tech gabe with his tech talk i don't
know organic engagement will be lacking
no product innovation yeah it's gonna
look exactly the same as twitter like
exactly the same ghost town in six to
nine months you're you're being very
generous gabe
you're being very [ __ ] generous
about truth social here
um
giving it six to nine months
uh here he says just downloaded the app
he was downloading the app last night i
just downloaded the app i've been unable
to create an account
clicking the link create new account
gives you the following error screen so
here's what it looked like oh sorry
sorry
you don't get you don't get an account
you don't get an account
so he was trying to log in
um to the uh
the app and matt i'm gonna call out matt
here matt says
i do hope when you're entering your
personal information for signing up you
use tony michael's info and said come on
now god damn it
i'm relying on gabe to make up some kind
of fake information so when there's the
data leak because you know they're going
to infiltrate the data here like if you
go over and you enter your data into
true social no because these [ __ ]
these [ __ ] right-wing [ __ ] suck at
this tech stuff they are horrible at it
they are [ __ ] horrible at it
someone's going to get in there and get
that [ __ ] data and they're going to
leak it and they're going to dump it for
[ __ ] sure
he said you know for when they get
hacked
matt says of course
yeah matt
don't give gabe any good ideas god damn
it um and i said me me with them of
course
um
let's see what else do we have here on
true social
ah
oh let's go
we were down in the rabbit hole there i
think we have i think i had some more on
true social here
somewheres somewheres maybe we'll go to
the thread let's go the tweet tweets oh
here this is this is a this is what i
this one i wrote
would who would pay good [ __ ] money
for these gq peers to delete their
twitter accounts and slither over the
trump's true social so apparently
and i don't know if this is true or not
i guess we'll find out as
as we log in
as we log in oh here we go here we go
here's gabe i think it's actually gabe
that's joining us today gabe how are you
this morning yeah i heard you talking
about me oh did you yeah yeah all right
yeah i was talking i was talking i was
talking [ __ ] you know i know i know
let's
let's let's dig into this the reason i
gave six and now i think all of these
things are going to be true now
a friend of mine does so these these are
your predictions
now i i have a background in
uh in tech i'm a product designer and
yeah you were you were saying some
things here that i i have no idea what
the [ __ ] you were right here you want to
go back to it i'll break it down for you
yeah yeah let me let me let me pull it
up here there we go okay okay let's pull
the bait so
my predictions were that uh people would
have an issue signing up creating an
account and then also signing in right
so so and which your prediction is
already with your experience so far has
already come true right right so that
happened check check out d-a-u and m-a-u
are daily active users and monthly
active users
it's a metric that you use to
measure the activity within an app to
say like okay great we're getting like
we set a benchmark here and this is what
we expect now i'm sure like like the
business model is viable because right
exactly because you've got you have
investors right and these people want to
see the numbers to show like okay the
money i'm putting into this thing is
actually going to return something later
on if we decide to
uh
bring in any sort of upsell or
advertising or anything like that
because because what you're saying there
because that's that's actually crucially
important to this whole [ __ ] business
model because they tried to well i mean
they went public with this thing before
it ever really existed and then and then
when the after the all these investors
dumped you know it's like a pump and
dump they pumped all this money into it
and then they lost their asses on it but
that's when they released like what it
was actually gonna be and it's like an
exact copy right yeah and also keep in
mind the other thing i didn't even
include in here was this this app has
been already like redesigned since the
initial like we're coming out with this
uh this app
so that the design that we see today is
different than design that was
advertised and also
shown in the app store which is not
uncommon
but it just goes to show you
that the initial design wasn't close
enough to twitter
that they had to then make a copy that
was even more like twitter right well
and i want to i want to bring that up
when we get down to this no product
innovation right um but you said organic
engagement will be lacking what makes
you think what makes you think that
organic activity will be engagement will
be lacking so i wouldn't be surprised if
they had already started seeding so
seeding in in um
in a tech standpoint is when
uh
you
you put in content beforehand to make it
seem like there is already activity
happening but you mean you mean before
like the app opens up and all these
right so you'll want a seat activity
conversations to say like
uh hey you know john doe what's going on
maga for life all that [ __ ] right
right right right so if you wanted to 24
that kind of right right if you wanted
to push a message or a narrative right
in the app that you control you know
that ecosystem well i say ecosystem
because it's not really one but if you
wanted to control the message within
that domain
that is how you would do it right you
would start to in to to get
right because you would create an echo
chamber of people who wanted to say the
same thing but instead of feeling like
you were hesitant or shy about being the
first one to say something you'd already
have fake users fake users right right
there'd already be conversations that
people could jump in on exactly right
now these could be actual
users or bots they could be real
accounts but they've already begun the
conversation by saying hey this is the
best app ever or like oh man it's so
great to get away from twitter and have
our free voices
or some [ __ ] like that right freedom
right i'm sure that means so
that's why i say organic engagement will
be lacking because i think they're going
to artificially
uh inject conversations and topics into
the app which isn't necessarily um
a new thing that has been done for other
apps right there's other there's other
these tactics to get people to start
conversations and to get them engaged
however i don't feel like the engagement
is going to be sustaining
in the app long enough to get them to
something to say like this app is is
totally viral right there's a viral
coefficient as well that goes with apps
to say like let's say that i i post
something in the app
and i want to share it i will i in my
mind right now i have no idea how that
that sharing component happens right
because
you share it out are there going to be a
a public viewable interface that people
can interact with you know like you
would see on twitter and facebook maybe
right that would be like not reinventing
the wheel but
uh i can't say for certain that uh that
trump wouldn't be dumb enough to try to
to to to gatekeep people out
so if you've shared something and i was
like hey come check this thing out on
truth social someone tried to go in and
like oh in order to view it you got to
make an account which is so nice so in
other words so in other words like um
because facebook does this a lot right
like you gotta log into your facebook if
you click on like a facebook link right
if you interact like if someone shared
it
and then you wanted to interact with
that that link that took they like they
text it to you right like they right
hey look at this look at this post on
true social media right
and then click on the ring right
typically what you would see in other
apps is i could actually see what that
page is now again i don't know what this
looks like because i'm unable to
actually get in the app as well as
many many other people that i've been
like documenting online
but what i've seen is
typically what you'll have is i share a
link you can see a a
a a public view of that however you
can't interact you can't like you can't
share you can't comment you can't you
know whatever you want to do with it
because in order to interact with it you
have to have an account to actually log
that
additional user interaction with it
right
now if they share it i don't know what
that looks like uh i would assume again
that they wouldn't reinvent the wheel
but i wouldn't put past them to try to
gatekeep or like you know it's what you
see sometimes when you go read an
article there's like a paywall kind of
thing where you can't see
you know because you have to log in or
pay whatever not saying that they have
to pay because that ended up being
a uh a debunked rumor okay so so let's
talk about that because the organic
engagement that you're talking about the
lack of it is going to be because
twitter you can go search twitter
without logging in like there's some
there's some things that you can't do
obviously but you can you can go look at
the archive like you can see
everyone's account if you're not logged
in like on a web browser right yeah so
you're saying the organic engagement is
going to be low because they're not
going to just allow that right yeah but
i also think that just the conversation
itself are going to be like very
one-dimensional right you're going to
have to you're going to have the people
who are like pushing a bunch of
conspiracies and the people that are
pushing because remember this is free
speech there's going to be like
literally freezing yeah yeah there's
gonna be little that is left
to
uh
that you can't talk about right there's
obviously gonna be like you know no
pornography and no this and all that but
for the most part they've advertised
this as a
free speech
totally open model no pornography so
that that that's a good idea maybe maybe
now that the ottawa occupation is over
maybe the ram ranchers
i'm just i'm just throwing out ideas
here so let's get to the product no
product innovation because i saw this
morning and maybe maybe this is a
debunked thing too because we'll talk
about the the the
the amount in um
in
in uh
uh
the the
the lie about the the weekly charge why
about the weekly journal right
um i got this so 4.99 a week is a myth
it's been debunked snopes debunked it
so where did that come from where did
that come from it came from there was
another screenshot that was taken from
another app and what ended up happening
was somebody tweeted out or shared it on
facebook wit and misled people to
believe that this was
uh trump's app but it was actually a
different app
so it's not actually 4.99 a week but
though at the same time it's like i
wouldn't put it past him well i mean it
sounds right right it does sounds right
it's one of those things where it's like
oh this is is this parody you know you
know the best part you know the best
part about that though is because these
[ __ ] always use these lies to try to
try to [ __ ] you know put wrenches in
the system right and here it here here
is a [ __ ] lie that is totally
believable that will probably keep trump
supporters off the app because they
think it costs five bucks because if
they spread because this lie spread
around so fast and they believe every
[ __ ] thing they hear
so because they believe everything they
[ __ ] hear and they're not willing to
uncouple it from their brain right like
if they hear a lie and they're like oh
well now it's a lie i can undo that as a
truth in my head nope they got to
continue this lie right right that may
that may hurt the organic engagement
just because they're not going to go
over to the act because yeah there's
money there could be people who are
there's a deterrent because people
believe that because there is a cost
they don't want to sign up now that's
you know i don't know these people are
so [ __ ] gullible and they might just
pay to pay
and end up you know paying some random
person through paypal because they were
told that they should you know i'm not
saying that they would do that but it's
not outside the like possibility that
somebody would feel duped or or rather
would be duped into doing that right but
let's get to the product innovation
because i seen this morning there's like
and maybe this is these would be
debunked too but he stole he stole the
[ __ ] logo like the what's what's the
little app though
yeah apparently i don't know that is
possible i mean here's the thing like
there a lot of companies steal logos and
i actually have
a book somewhere in my apartment here
that uh
that is
logos over time right right like if they
are like even airbnb logo like that's a
that's a uber
uber right these are all logos that have
been either used or
modified from
other legitimate companies because a lot
of them are just like
really
very common fonts right they're just
arranged in a certain way or right you
know stacked in a certain order or
something yeah i i don't know uh
i mean here i'm looking i'm reading this
independent article right now that says
uh
truth social trump threatened with legal
action by a little known british company
with identical logo right um i don't
know what the company is
it's called trailer
and both logos use a block style shape
that form the letter t making truth
social a target of dozens comparisons of
the logo of the british firm interesting
but it doesn't it doesn't surprise me
that trump would steal a logo right oh
no
so the logos are very similar the only
difference is that they modified it by
here i could uh well here here i i think
yeah send me the link and we'll pull it
up here yeah so the the logos are are
very similar um the only difference is
he added a
uh
a little block or something that's what
i look like on the bottom yeah like a
green little box right exactly and so
when you look at the two you say
oh yeah these are uh
these are nearly identical right like
i'm i mean you know the trailer one is a
little bit longer in the t stem
than right uh so here they are and the
trump one but so this is the trump one
right right that's too social and then
this is the other one which i mean other
than the color in the little green box
right right but also the color is like
you're you know you're a change in hue
here on the background and i'm sure i
could match the same thing if i add a
neon
green block again different colors than
what was originally advertised when the
when the uh
you're talking about when they first
when they first advertised it and
they're like hey you can like um
you can sign up to download the app you
know the wait list or whatever uh or the
uh get notified when it does go live
there's a different different design to
it it's like is this the actual company
yeah this is uh i believe that's the
actual company to see donald supports
some uh so this is a
british company yeah this is the british
company that's claiming our people are
claiming that the logo is stolen which
it if you go look at it it does i'm
gonna retweet it here great to see
donald trump supporting a growing
substantial effect
making uh maybe ass next time so
basically they're saying thanks for
supporting our uh thanks for supporting
our brand trump and making us known all
around the world for the logo that you
stole yeah so this is i mean here's what
i love how they're trying to killing
someone's brand is totally on brand for
trump well yeah absolutely you know so
but tell us tell us because you live in
this world of like logos and design and
what you can and can't do it's totally
legitimate to for him the pi i mean
maybe there's legalization i mean
another country but yeah it's it is i
mean obviously different you know
different laws and different rules for
different places but i mean like you
know logos are uh trademarked and you
know
um
it's a big issue if it's a similar logo
in a similar industry right so this is a
little bit different this is a solar
energy company right he's a social you
know social company right yeah
grifter agreement
but if you if you worked like let's say
i wanted to open a shoe company and i
made a logo that was like very similar
to nike right uh nike would just bury me
in lawsuits right and
that would be illegal because i could
possibly cause confusion within the
marketplace to say like oh yeah that
shoe that looks like nike i assumed it
was a nike shoe
and that's where you have um brand
confusion
and typically if you're a smaller
company going up against a bigger
company
uh i mean in a room full of lawyers
right right you're done and uh i look at
this and i say like they're not the same
industry the logos are very similar
yet
different so there's probably no lawsuit
or no case here but it does go to the
fact of like the guy couldn't even come
up with an original concept for his
[ __ ] social app right right he stole
the interface the interface looks almost
identical to twitter he uh uh other
other than other than the chicks are
right
yeah soviet red checks right exactly
instead of the blue or the black it's
just red the soviet right
you know
but when i say product innovation what i
mean is
the app in itself is going to use the
same features that you see
on facebook on twitter on instagram like
keep in mind these companies
while in their own kind of field
they do copy from each other right like
you had insta instagram made instagram
stories then facebook obviously owns
instagram so they adopted those in
twitter made twitter fleets which is a
copy of instagram stories right linkedin
even made stories uh these are all
things that someone says oh great
there's there's market there's like
traction or mark market adoption within
this feature
uh people really like it let's see if we
can use that in our own app as well and
then call it something else but
that's like twitter has twitter spaces
and it's kind of a copy of like the
clubhouse app exactly and i look at
clubhouse and i say that's not really a
product that's just like a feature right
right you know but it is what it is
so i look at that and it's kind of
similar how steve jobs called dropbox a
feature not a product right because he
was like well it's just file sharing
there's nothing really innovative about
it you're just sharing the permissions
now obviously from there they've
modified and allow you to interact with
things so it's become more of a product
than a feature but
um
yeah so there's gonna be no product
innovation everything that you see there
is going to be everything you've seen
before from every other social app
they're just going to pull and copy it's
going to pull and copy pull and copy and
they're going to do it you don't think
they'll do it in a way that they'll
they'll actually keep users because
that's that's sometimes social media has
a trouble with that like like for
instance tick-tock became really popular
and that's where a lot of these uh
facebook and all the and youtube went to
shorts like they were like oh my god
this is a huge market and they tried it
and they're just it's just not the same
right like right it's not the same or
the fact that it takes them longer than
anticipated to
uh to adjust that feature right and to
say they go like youtube uh shorts that
took
months like
uh i think they tested it in india and
then they did a test here but there
really wasn't a full-on test you had to
tag it in a certain way right and then
you also had to be larger uh larger
creators or influencers on the platform
those were people that were going to be
able to use it so i mean like you know
they're using that to generate hype like
oh my god they're using shorts i can't
wait to use shorts right like right
you're using this tactic of
uh of of using influence to network an
idea or a concept to you know to draw
attention now that also goes into
another thing i'm going to talk about in
a second but that's what i mean mark no
mar no uh product innovation it means
that this app is going to be a clone
copy of everything we've seen before so
it's nothing new yeah nothing new
they're probably going to try to upsell
you on something you know maybe you can
buy some [ __ ] stickers or whatever i
don't know what the [ __ ] is going to
happen right they'll probably be
definitely going to be a griff though
that you have right right the only the
only way and so this is when people were
like you you especially be like oh 69
months you're being real generous
this is why i believe that all right be
up to six nine months
they've uh at least tentatively and
they've talked about it and so is rumble
rumble which is the open like free
speech platform for video sharing
is going to be
the uh the the back end service for
video sharing on truth social okay so so
explain that what do you mean by back
end so is it like
so they're their bet piggybacking on
another right so instead of instead of
creating or developing your own video
sharing uh
i mean
kind of like is it kind of like on i
mean i mean are they gonna be able to
retweet videos is it kind of like
periscope was to twitter or yeah i mean
like they're using you know i forget the
the timeline of one periscope came in
with with video if it was before and
then they adopted it and they said great
uh but i know that live sharing because
that's what periscope was before and i
think that was really the feature that
they adopted right into uh into twitter
but what i mean is
so instead of creating something from
scratch to say like hey we support video
sharing right
they're going to use rumble which is
already an established platform and
service that you can upload share
cut snippet whatever it's like what all
of the other people use like oan that's
why you see all of their [ __ ] on there
all right wing people
everyone is pushing a conspiracy is
there because everywhere else they're
getting completely thrown off because
it's all debunked stuff or it's like
this
right wing or or or
hate speech or whatever it is is getting
is getting removed from other platforms
and this is a place where you could say
whatever and however
yeah i mean unless and unless it's
against them and then it probably right
right unless it's against them yeah and
obviously they'll suppress it or kill
whatever but rumble's gonna be the
service that supports video in the app
right so you can upload a photo as
normal and then the video component is
what is being driven that's powered by
rumble so in other words you're gonna
have to upload your video on rumble and
then no no no no no no that's what i'm
saying what i'm saying is like you can
upload a video rumble and share it on
truth but when you upload a video
through it's just going on rumble it's
being supported by rumble now i don't
know if it's gonna have parodies so that
it goes over to rumble but it will stay
on true social and the video component
is powered by rumble now the reason that
i say six to nine months before it
becomes a ghost town is because i
believe
that there can be enough activity to
keep this thing just like above water
right or like up coming up for breath
and then going down and coming up for
breath and going down
ever so often
uh for the app now in the next nine
months there remember the events that
are gonna be happening we've got the
midterms coming up right right so i
think don't you think that's why the
release came so fast is because yeah
there's a lot of indictments coming uh
right he's in big trouble so he wants to
be able to to get his message out there
exactly yeah um and then the midterms
are coming i think that's why they're
pushing it out so quickly yeah yeah and
so i look at that and i say okay well
you got the midterms coming up in
november and they're going to be ramping
up this summer into the fall to start
you know promoting and campaigning and
debates and whatever else and all this
stuff and so they're going to use this
as an app to push
whatever narrative they want right
because it's free speech you can post
you can say whatever and they're going
to push that as its own echo chamber
right we've seen it with parlor parlor
obviously you know nobody trusts parlor
anymore because all their [ __ ] was
hacked right and it was shared to fbi uh
you know right uh
right people invested yeah well because
of january 6 right exactly
but now the idea is that uh
when i look at this i say okay we're
leading up to a major event a milestone
and that needs to sustain itself and
after that we'll see what happens but i
think
by nine months it becomes relatively a
ghost town because i don't think there's
gonna be enough people actually talking
about [ __ ] what i think is gonna be
happening is uh people who are running
for office uh campaign managers people
who are running the social other people
they've got like as plants people that
are or you know maybe paid on the uh uh
behind closed doors to great post you
know
those people are going to keep activity
going and they're going to be pushing
you know the big lie and they're going
to be pushing this other narrative and
those are going to be bigger voices and
those bigger voices are going to be
amplified artificially and somewhat
organically
by actual users in the app but i think
if you were to drop all of that from the
side you wouldn't have anything to
sustain the app right so that's why 69
months now i don't think people
anticipate i saw a lot of people were
like oh yeah six to nine days six to
nine weeks that's funny how i think how
many scaramucci's is what i want right
right exactly they're like two scary
moochies and in my mind because i'm from
a product world i'm like what events are
happening and what would actually keep
this thing moving
till that point or like for the next
nine months
it's the midterms so let me ask you two
because like
you see tick-tock right and tick-tock
got huge and then there was this and and
but you know it was literally like a
child dancing app right like a trinidad
dancing yeah it was a previous app that
got rebranded and then and then what
happened was the politics started to
play in with the 2020 election and you
had the two sides of tick tock you had
the moga side and then the the liberal
side right of tic tac and then
tick tock seemed to be censoring
um
some of the political speech on tic-tac
after the 2020 election and then even
after january 6. so a lot of people left
tick tock to go to what was called
clapper
um
and i don't eat this clapper even is it
even a clapper i believe still exists
because they advertise themselves as the
like phrase free free speech platform
and i i'm even on there they brought me
over like hey listen if you post you
know three things and do this we'll give
you the verified check mark and i was
like all right cool fine i'll do that
and like have you been over there since
i posted some things and it's like back
in my mind i never remember to do it
right when i originally did it some
things would blow up but holy [ __ ] the
interface was terrible the ux was
terrible so let me ask you is this the
same thing is this the same i mean the
same kind of because i noticed that
aesthetically it looks better because
it's using twitter as the model now i
don't know what the actual interaction
is going to be like i can tell you from
my experience of just trying to sign up
and create an account it was [ __ ] dog
[ __ ] okay so talk about that talk about
your experience because so matt matt
tried to get you to use my information
you son of a no i'm just kidding
obviously he was kidding but yeah yeah
so so what happened so last night i i
did that i did that tweet and i was like
all right whatever and then i find out
that it actually you know it actually
was officially live right so i download
the app you know
cool great
so you were able to download it on the
apple store or the
yeah i download it on because that's is
that the only place that it's actually
available is the apple uh as of right
now yeah which is very surprising
because android doesn't have
uh well here's the thing two things i
believe you
apple is the only the app store is the
only one that allows you to like
have a waiting period to say we're going
to launch on this day when it finally uh
does go live then you can download it on
android there's really no approval
process from my experience
uh you submitted app and it gets
reviewed and that's why you find a lot
of shady apps on the android play store
because
uh
they don't really get reviewed like they
you give me you mean by samsung itself
before it goes on the store we'll buy
google because they're the ones that
well right right sorry so because like
apple has technically they have a
legitimate review process as long as the
app seems like it's working it should
work then they will say great there's
nothing malicious here there's nothing
that's going to steal data you know
because privacy is a big thing do you
think maybe that's why they did that
though is to like this ruse that a i
think i think they used apple as the
first one because they wanted to drive
up hype right they wanted people to say
oh great boom because it's safe it's
safe in other words it's safe but also
it's the only one that allows someone to
pre-install so you say oh yeah sign me
up so then when i see what you're saying
like the pre-order because they were
they were tweeting out the pre-orders
exactly right yeah exactly so once that
goes live the pre-order becomes a
legitimate order aka a download it gets
downloaded onto your phone but android
you can't do that in their uh their app
store you have to download it at the
moment now they they they might support
uh android i don't know uh it's
obviously a different code base and and
uh i mean you could do it through other
things like react but in my mind react
is a
no
unless react is a a programming language
that allows you to do different types of
platforms so you could do react so you
could basically download an apple
app on your well yeah you design it's
called react native and so you design
the app and you're like great i can
design this component so when i ship it
it goes out and looks like ios i ship it
it looks like android i ship it it looks
like this right so these are you know
you make a react native website all
these different things so anyway uh i've
had more headache than i can
handle from that so i would imagine
these are uh
these are
uh code like these are platform specific
um
designs so i don't know when they will
if they will do android uh but they've
obviously launched with ios on the
iphone so yeah so so that that that
brings me to it to a question here about
the you know ios and you know
trying to make it seem legitimate
possibly
but really at the end of the day
do they have this launchable by the end
of the day or tomorrow do you think i
mean because really i mean think about
this this is what trump always does
right he always does this like he has
this big hype he's got this this fraud
that he's trying to sell right like
trump stakes like trump sticks are the
best ever and it lasted like three
[ __ ] days because it couldn't launch
yeah because there wasn't anything there
it was all [ __ ] it was just a video
that he did right so do you do you think
that it actually like because it is
apple so they have said that it's
launchable essentially but do you think
it actually gets up and running to where
they can because what's the back end
look like yeah they have a certain
amount of servers or something right
this is what i think happened right so
you
and this goes into another point that i
experienced uh later on because people
were like oh i'm you know i'm in the i'm
i here's my screenshot of the wait list
can't wait right
this is what i think um
about that uh i think
so for your first question you've got
apple apple goes through a review
process for the code they say this looks
good nothing malicious here we're gonna
go we give you approval and then within
a few days it goes live right now from
that point it is solely dependent
assuming the code
looks good from their their dev team to
review
uh and their qa team
that uh this is actually a true social
issue this means that on their end on
truth socials end
they
there is a bug in the system either they
weren't anticipating the demand that was
happening or they didn't do properly qa
testing or there's some connection
between how accounts are created in the
database
from
when you enter info to how it's saved or
what the actual flow should be because
the optimal flow from what i've seen in
some screenshots is you get to the thing
it says do you want to sign in or create
an account i want to create an account i
go there i have to indicate what my
birthday is then from there i have to
enter an email then from there it says
great we sent you a verification email
standard kind of onboarding flow right
however
what happens
in this experience for several people
outside not just myself is click that
screenshot yep you get an error that
says
uh something went wrong
right
which is not ideal there's no context of
what we're wrong you get a random vague
error and i'm this is just me trying to
click create an account
just so this is not doing anything weird
like i forgot my password
i mean i didn't even try that uh i just
tried create my account create my
account i would get this screen then
we're trying to are trying to do a
workaround where you try to get into the
app right exactly there was nothing that
would allow me i just got this errors
like something went wrong please try
again then i was like okay fine took
some time off came back tried it again
got to the birthday
same error something went wrong please
try again okay fine so little by little
you're getting each npc yeah but every
time i try i mean like i might click
please you know create an account create
an account create account and then i'm
led into the next step right and then i
get the next step and it's like air air
air air and i'm like [ __ ] this so then i
leave and i come back again later
while i'm watching tv or a movie last
night and i click and i get through to
the email
same air same air same air same air i
even got to the email screen
and
submitted my email
and it said hey congrats uh or whatever
we sent you an email to verify
i never got a [ __ ] email still
haven't i still have not got an email
are you able to sign into this thing at
this point no because i haven't set a
password oh okay because you're doing
right so i need to verify create the and
i have to go to those steps right there
right there's a bit of like this is
making sure that you
you're getting legitimate people or when
i say legitimate people you're getting
real people right in the app that are
creating accounts right because they
they they really at this point don't
want it completely infiltrated by all
fake accounts because that would be that
would be like a a knife almost
immediately right like if it's all fake
right yeah i mean at some point they
want it to be fake right right yeah i
mean they want you know obviously fake
uh
they want fake interactions in there to
make it look like real interactions but
the problem is if you can't get people
in to actually interact with those fake
interactions then the app is [ __ ]
bust and then what i saw was people were
sending me messages about how they got a
uh congrats your uh you're on the wait
you're on the wait list right
which was
um if you go back to that tweet
yeah let me uh uh let's see what the the
this one here
uh the start of the three back to the
original yeah and scroll down so i know
somebody added uh keep scrolling down
somebody added a screenshot of them on
the waitlist
oh okay like uh um like right there boom
okay so i'll give context to people who
have not seen this or you know have no
interest to actually interact with this
app
your account has been created
successfully okay and it said due to the
demand
then uh
we are
uh
you know it says thank for joining due
to massive demand we have placed you on
our wait list we love you and you're not
just another number to us you totally
are but your waitlist number is below
7717
right so do you think that's a fake
number like they're trying to bolster
that number or do you think i think this
whole thing is fake and the reason i
think is screenshots fake no no no i
think the screenshots no no no no what i
mean though is like it that the screen
grab is obviously real but what i'm
saying is the screen this message that
someone is getting is bogus it's not
nothing in this is true so this is this
is what i what i think happened uh and
this tactic is also not new to designing
an app right the idea here
is that you want to create exclusivity
there's a hype of demand that is not
actually there
right but it creates people talking it
creates a buzz people want to know what
it is people want to download oh [ __ ]
i'm this one oh i'm in this way these
waitlists are a real thing that have
launched i've worked at companies where
we've done this you know to hype up
demand and it does work so another
another one
in the industrial [ __ ] works this
works so in other words in the initial
planning
in these apps sometimes in design
designers are are saying okay we need to
make sure we have a waitlist and we have
designs that we're going to pump out
when people end up on the quote unquote
waitlist is that right but it's also
it's also one of these things where you
go in saying
if we can't handle there's a few things
it's like if we can't handle the traffic
or even
low or high amount of traffic because
people can't sign up we need something
to send someone if we can but also
that's the assumption that someone can
actually go through the creation of the
uh account successfully that's we have
to do to get to this screen however
what's happening here is some people are
getting through to this screen and
everyone else can't even get through the
create an account link right so what's
what's happening is some people get the
account created and they're put on a
waitlist now my professional assessment
as an engineer and a designer is that
what they did here was they created this
to artificially hype up or inflate
demand which is great totally something
trump would do
right but i look at it and i see
you make this screen they've signed up
and you put them on a waitlist
so now people have waited essentially
twice they've waited once because they
pre-ordered and the second time because
now they're on a wait list
and then
they will
slowly allow people in you know whether
it's for crowd control
or whether it's because they just wanted
to hype up demand and make it seem like
everyone wanted to do it so just
intentionally make people exactly
because you know you know the best part
about this statement here this little
graphic is you know due to high demand
we placed on a way it says we
love you do you remember where when when
he said that as well what remember
remember the the famous uh uh statement
that he made on january 6 which caused
him to actually that's the actual video
that caused him to be taken down from
all the social media platforms
eventually you know over the next few
days he said
we
love you in that [ __ ] phrase that is
[ __ ] hilarious i'm i'm almost
surprised that they didn't even tell
people to stand back and stand by
like well like hey
stand back yeah like stand by maybe he
should have had a little had a little
video that he made you're on the wait
list and i think maybe maybe maybe
there's a maybe there's a video there
for uh
our friend our friend john walsh i know
um i'm just you know floating around
right there i'm going to join the wait
list right join the weight loss what i
find funny about this is that he's like
thanks for joining due to the massive
van that we created
it is no demand that what has happened
here is he created demand
and it would only this would only work
if there weren't a ton of errors in the
beginning right like if you were able to
create an account great boom oh wow okay
well it seems a little odd but i'm on a
waitlist yeah usual mj mj points out a
good point here mj says you're not a
number you're just number
7717 right
it goes
you're not just another number to us but
your weightless number is
and you're like great you know whether
that's actually 7 717 people i highly
doubt
uh
but you know it is what it is can you
imagine the [ __ ] they got number
six six six you know you know these
people they freak out you know i'm sure
that's like i'm sure somebody got it i
saw only two two of these out there one
was four thousand and one was seven
thousand okay so they're not like
pumping out the same number no no no i
mean that would be funny too but i
imagine what's gonna happen is you could
also hit the refresh icon there and it
would update your number to be like oh
great i'm number seven seven oh okay
down the list exactly yeah which is
probably just probably just a [ __ ]
automated thing that yeah it's like
every three sec if somebody programmed
it right it would be like randomly go
every few seconds or whatever it is
so that's what i say this app is [ __ ]
dog [ __ ] it's got no product in
innovation the only thing that's going
to keep it moving is the midterms and
trying to push the agenda and narrative
of the republican party or the gqp up
until through november so i don't see
this app actually working how they want
it
to work i think it's going to be a
[ __ ] ghost town
after the midterms but that's that's
just me and that again that's only one
person's opinion but that's also based
on you but i guess your industry but i
guess you're
you're you're doing the assumption that
they're possibly doing this just for the
midterms which i think that's pop
probably
i don't think they're only doing the
midterms i think they're doing it but i
think the midterms is what's going to
drive the engagement or activity inside
the app in a somewhat organic fashion
it's not going to be enough but what are
they do do you think because um
we elected joe biden right and and after
january 6 happened uh well i'll say this
from the election until january 6 yeah
social media really let down their guard
right we know that now from the
whistleblower uh the facebook
whistleblower that said look they had
policies in place to kind of you know
stop some of this stuff from from taking
hold of people's minds actual users
minds and they took a lot of that stuff
away right those tools that social media
could use to not spread as much
disinformation and misinformation right
to
dilute the masses but after january 6
they got and after january 20th when joe
biden took office they kind of let all
of that go
so
why why do you think the gqp or the
republicans of the fascists are so
[ __ ] concerned because i'll be honest
with you twitter is a swamp
like yeah i mean twitter's not great if
you if if anyone was on twitter
yesterday they noticed the the portland
and andy know [ __ ] yeah where
someone was shot um and just the actual
the absolute [ __ ] vile fascist nazi
ass [ __ ] that these [ __ ] were
saying these andy knows supporters
yesterday and you think that do you
think that you can't propagate a [ __ ]
right wing message on twitter get the
[ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ] andy no
this morning is still active and his
tweets are still there now um which you
know i i don't mean to get off the topic
of social but you know i i actually
message you there was a screen capture
thing or our tweet capture thing um and
it's probably going to be very hard to
infiltrate some of these deletions of
the true social you know deleting the
truth but tell us a little bit about um
this deleting thing did you investigate
that at all of how this is working on
um especially in this situation where
these
these morons are tweeting stuff that
probably is against terms of service but
might even
be um illegal because it has to do with
the illegal activity that happened at
the shooting in portland um what is what
what is that thing that everyone's
talking about where you're able to go
back and see tweets that have been
deleted oh okay so uh
there's a there's a tool online that's
called um
uh you know way back machine right
right
and we talked about that in an interview
that's interview you're right
with a certain someone about a certain
thing happening in canada
um
so uh which i actually have a clip uh
for us to show um oh dewey yeah yeah
okay yeah good good go ahead so um
the